[Music]
just struck out the best hitter on their
team i didn't expect to see that today
they better follow up with someone good
if they want to win
one out bottom of the ninth and they
want me to go up
we're one point away from winning
but my batting average isn't what it
used to be
no they put me here for a reason i just
need to get to first and it'll be smooth
sailing from there
wait
they're communicating if i could figure
out their code
wow that's his fastest pitch of the day
does kirby stand a chance according to
his stats
unlikely
wait what's he doing what's that symbol
mean
that's a jungle that's against the rules
today's not your day kid
it's time to witness my power
[Music]
junk ball has a spinning gyroscope in
its center making its movement
unpredictable
it's impossible to hit
no
i can't win
not against that
i've been on this team 10 years and i've
never seen a pitch like that
[Music]
i've got to do something
wait a minute
he switched balls that's an illegal
the signal i need that now for that
strike three
i might not be going home today
but kirby sure is
dodger
now what is he doing stealing second
base but he's never gonna make it
euromast soup is just too fast
[Music]
if he turns back they'll just throw the
ball back to first and they'll tag him
out what is he thinking
[Applause]
[Music]
he switched the baseballs
he doesn't notice
dodgers sacrificed himself for me
so i can win the game
[Music]
i'm knocking this one right
this one's for you doctor
[Music]
is
grand slam for my friend